Півтора тижня світ з острахом спостерігав, як палає Чорнобильська зона -
радіоактивний анклав розміром з Люксембург за сто кілометрів від Києва.
Пожежу, що стала найбільшою з часів аварії на ЧАЕС,
вдалося приборкати лише на десятий день -
завдяки героїзму сотень пожежників і волонтерів, пожежній авіації та - дощу.
І хоча вогонь, що впритул підійшов до атомної станції,
наразі вдалось зупинити, а рівень радіації навіть у прилеглих районах не перевищує норми,
радіти зарано:
радіоактивні ліси навколо реактора будь-якої миті можуть спалахнути знову -
вважає Ярослав Ємельяненко, голова "Асоціації чорнобильських туроператорів"
та член громадської ради
при Державному агентстві з управління зоною відчуження.
За його словами, чорнобильські ліси беззахисні перед навмисними і ненавмисними підпалами -
адже потрапити у нібито
закриту зону насправді дуже легко:
цим роками користуються
так звані сталкери - нелегальні туристи.
Серед них є багато
неадекватних людей,
про мотиви яких ми можемо
лише здогадуватися.
Коли на цю небезпечну, радіоактивну територію
нелегально приходять люди, вони можуть зробити там що завгодно -
щось підпалити, потрощити,
розфарбувати.
Останніми роками
було багато акцій вандалізму.
Покарання за нелегальне проникнення у режимну зону навколо реактора наразі символічне -
нелегалам, якщо їх спіймають, загрожує адміністративний штраф
розміром трохи більше 300 гривень.
За словами Ярослава Ємельяненка,
сталкери інколи навіть самі викликають поліцію, якщо їм набридає ходити пішки -
таке собі бюджетне чорнобильське таксі.
Потрібно закривати периметр зони.
Треба ставити камери, паркани. Це закрита зона чи місце для прогулянок?
Якщо це місце для прогулянок - тоді будуть пожежі з усіма наслідками.
Наразі поліція встановила двох чоловіків, причетних до чорнобильських пожеж.
Обидва - мешканці сіл поблизу зони відчуження.
Один з них підпалив сміття та траву задля розваги. Інший - нібито через необережність.
В обох випадках вогонь перекинувся на чорнобильські ліси.
Утім, осередки займання були і в самій зоні,
повідомила DW
речниця Державної служби
з надзвичайних ситуацій у Київській області
Вікторія Рубан.
Ми не даємо однозначних версій.
Але фактом є те, що осередки знаходилися, по-перше, у важкодоступних місцях,
а по-друге, їх було дуже багато - в різних місцях і іноді на відстані десятків кілометрів.
Після повної ліквідації працівники поліції будуть з'ясовувати, чи це були підпали.
За словами Вікторії Рубан, щоб зменшити ризик виникнення пожеж,
потрібно розчищати вкрай захаращені чорнобильські ліси.
Наразі це заважає контролювати територію і уповільнює роботу пожежників,
які і без того працюють в  умовах радіаційної небезпеки.
На закиди, що пожежу гасили півтора тижні,
а впоратись з поширенням вогню допоміг дощ, у ДСНС запевняють:
швидше працювати не могли.
Кожного дня під час обльотів виявляються нові й нові осередки:
виявляються - гасяться, виявляються - знову гасяться.
Тим паче що, по-перше, це величезні площі, а по-друге, було дуже багато місць,
де практично немає вододжерел, тому підвозом води довелося гасити.
Розумієте, ніхто ж не ставив завдання за годину чи дві загасити,
тому що насамперед було питання безпеки працівників ДСНС.
У ДСНС запевняють, що пожежники
регулярно проходять дозиметричний контроль,
від радіації не постраждали
та забезпечені усім необхідним.
Утім, люди, залучені
до гасіння пожеж,
розповідають, що це
не зовсім відповідає дійсності.
До КПП "Дитятки" - воріт у зону відчуження -
небайдужі люди привозять воду, їжу, респіратори та навіть шкарпетки для пожежників.
Потрапити у зону на відміну від сталкерів вони не можуть.
Тож, від шлагбаума допомогу забирають ті, хто має перепустку.
Секретар громадської ради при Держагентстві з управління зоною відчуження Максим Вірич
на пожежі - з перших днів. Каже, без волонтерів - ніяк.
Волонтерська допомога зараз дуже важлива. Основної техніки, в принципі, достатньо.
Не вистачає такої техніки, яка допомагає людям.
У першу чергу це... Ну, почнемо з найпростішого - рукавиці для захисту рук,
адже люди працюють в умовах високої температури.
Захист обличчя, захист зору. Який захист від радіації?
Як це називається? Респіратор фільтруючий.
А респіраторів вистачає?
Ні. Вони є, але хотілося б більше.
Нині експерти та екологи підраховують величезну шкоду,
яку пожежа завдала зокрема флорі і фауні Чорнобильського заповідника.
А пожежники та волонтери тим часом працюють над остаточною ліквідацією пожеж -
хоча відкритого вогню вже немає, у чорнобильській зоні все ще тліє.
І готуються до нових викликів - адже попереду ще п'ять спекотних місяців.